the premiere of the wendy williams show
has been delayed again i said what
what on thursday it was announced that
the rescheduled october 4th premiere is
no longer happening as wendy continues
to face health struggles after sharing
the news on the show's instagram account
they added that wendy has been and
continues to be under a doctor's care
and is not ready to return to work but
the plan is to return with new shows
starting october 18th the statement did
not go into detail about what led to the
additional delay but they did share
quote her breakthrough covid case is no
longer an issue and she has tested
negative but she is still dealing with
some ongoing medical issues no regrets
earlier this month a source told the t
that the 57 year old tv personality was
home and quote improving every day in
mid-september the show revealed that
wendy had tested positive for covid19
and they would be postponing the season
13 premiere in order for her to
quarantine and get better the newest
season of the wendy williams show was
scheduled to start on september 20th the
date was then moved to october 4th
earlier this month fans grew concerned
after the show announced that wendy was
dealing with ongoing health issues and
was undergoing further evaluation and
therefore would not be able to complete
her promotional appearances for the
upcoming season it's been a long summer
and we've got a lot to talk about
wendy's brother thomas williams jr
shared an update on her health during a
live stream on his youtube channel i did
speak with wendy she's she's stabilized
she's doing all right you know um i
can't give all the blow by blows i told
her i'll never precede her um
voice through the show i really
do believe and have the faith that
wendy's gonna make it
um you know it's it's not an easy fight
it's not one that uh individuals always
win many times i come up here and i
laugh and i joke but behind the scenes
i'm i'm i'm really uh
so thankful but this isn't the first
time wendy has taken time off of her
show due to health issues back in may
2020 she announced she would be taking a
step back to deal with health concerns
related to graves disease and in
february 2018 shortly after revealing
her diagnosis wendy told her viewers she
needed a break to handle her illness my
hyperthyroid is attached also to graves
disease i feel like they're birds
swimming around my head you know like a
cartoon
like
constantly high
but not high
when she came back that march she opened
up to dr oz about taking the time off i
had to take three weeks off of work
which was horrible
but needed get yourself checked out that
manicure and pedicure can wait take care
of yourself first
you